anyways we need to talk about these
winners what's your thoughts feelings
everything i think i felt like everyone
else felt in the theater when you when
we saw that uh performance last night it
was like wow what was that i mean it was
just sensational and you know three
times in a row now they have
collectively done something we've never
ever seen before
and you know sometimes you in in our
shows you can be in a little bit of a
bubble
in a bubble
and then you go home and you go she
wasn't as good as i thought this was
better it will
live outside of our show this act and i
just hope that we can give them the
start they
so what was the highlight for you for
this season
um
i think in terms of performances
probably that performance the girls did
last night was up there
in terms of one of the best i've ever
seen
so you're golden buzzer sarah james she
didn't get to the top five will you be
signing her though we know you have a
you know you have deals and stuff going
i personally don't run a record label
anymore however i think she will get a
deal and i think the important thing
with her is what does she learn from
this who what kind of artist does she
want to be
because there's a lot of people out
there making music right now and
the good thing is she's super focused
super talented really likable
massive massive talent by the way so
she's not going to give up i could just
feel it so you've created so many stars
what do you look for to be like what's
the talent what's the it factor that you
look for mainly people who sorry many
people who know
exactly like the winner's the ship
what their lane is you know who what do
they want to achieve
what can they do themselves
and
that epitomizes exactly what the show is
all about they don't need really our
help in anything other than we just
filmed them um and say how good they are
they put the hours in it's they their
vision they have an incredible
choreographer so yeah they epitomize
what this show is so another person
you've definitely found talent is in
harry styles and he's getting so much
oscar buzz for the policeman how house
has been seeing that journey like how is
that for you to see well i mean the
great thing about you know people like
harry or jennifer hudson kenny clark
whoever i mean i can name a lot leona
they've just
they've got their head start on the show
and then they do it themselves you know
and it's just this is like the kickstart
and it makes doing these shows
a reason for doing these shows so we
didn't find stars we'd like
what would have been the point there
would have been no point so i love all
that
you